I think I converged on the idea of being
a scientist fairly early on we took a
family trip to South Africa in 1998. we
went to Kruger National Park and I
recently found an old notebook where I
was counting all of them antelopes that
many people find quite boring I was
interested and engaged with the natural
world I was just really excited about it
I'm an ecologist of plants broadly but
more specifically I study Savannah
ecosystems Savannah ecosystems are where
trees and grass occur together
most of the fighters that burn on Earth
by a very large margin are Savannah
fires they have a large contribution to
the global carbon cycle fires take
carbon from the biosphere or from
essentially carbon that's stored in
plants and move it into the atmosphere
and so if we're going to predict
dynamics of the global carbon cycle
accurately including our fossil fuel
contributions to atmospheric CO2 we also
need to get a better handle on fire
contributions to the global carbon cycle
and by far the biggest contributor to
that are Savannah Fighters I use a lot
of different techniques in doing my
science we do a lot of remote sensing of
the environment essentially data that
are derived either from airplanes or
from satellites increasingly from drones
you essentially fly a drone over a fixed
plot and then you start a fire and you
watch the fire spread across the plot
and you concurrently record wind speed
you record air temperature you record
air humidity filming the fire allows you
to quantify how fire Behavior changes in
response to changing weather conditions
we actually started in excess of 1 100
experimental fires across Savannahs and
a variety of ecosystems we're really
interested in the question of what
extinguishes fires something that stops
a fire is really important determinant
of how big a fire gets and how much area
it's going to burn most fire ecologists
will tell you that they know why fires
go out it's for a variety of reasons but
why fires go out is not quantitatively
very well understood by anybody in any
ecosystem the most surprising thing that
we learned is that you can burn much
wetter grass than you would there could
be as much water as grass and it still
Burns perfectly fine which is not what
people typically assume and the way that
that happens is that as long as you can
get the fire started the heat that that
fire generates causes a lot of the water
Downstream from the fire front to
evaporate and then the fire becomes
self-sustaining that probably allows
fires to get bigger than we currently
think that they do under wetter
circumstances but it could also interact
with things like emissions factors wet
fires tend to be smokier fires that emit
different atmospheric byproducts and so
it could change some of the downstream
estimates that we make of what the
impacts of fires actually are there's a
lot to know and there's a lot to study
and what we know constitutes just a drop
in the bucket of what we should or need
to know